I am very shocked that I'm sitting here
right now house guests the votes are in
when I reveal the vote the evicted house
guest will have just a few moments to
say goodbye gather his or her belongings
and walk out the front door
buy a vote of five to zero
Kyle you are evicted from the Big
Brother house
at the first of the week I was I felt
like I was in a good spot but obviously
with some of the comments that I had
made earlier in the game
um that is definitely the reason why I'm
here now you had a conversation with
Michael saying that you thought there
could be an alliance in the house trying
to do what the cookout did last year
essentially being made up of all people
of color working together in a secret
Alliance and you proposed to Michael
that you and he plus Turner Alyssa and
Brittany
could work together in a secret Alliance
I accept that 100 and I look forward to
this journey moving forward and
continuing to learn and grow as a person
as terrible as it sound at the time it
didn't click in my mind and after
looking back in the multiple
conversations with Michael and Brittany
and multiple conversations you know this
week I now realize how terrible that was
and I should have realized it from the
start and I apologize to everyone
watching and everyone in the house I
made some generalized thoughts early in
the game in midday
him
um that definitely had no grounds and no
place in the game which are unfortunate
um I've talked with multiple individuals
this past week and they've been so open
and understanding and helping me learn
and again I take full responsibility in
moving forward it seemed like you guys
were on board with that I mean with that
plan though that obviously is not
something that we agreed to I understand
and I wish I had done things differently
I do feel at the same time it's not fair
for you to be the one making these
comments Michael and Brittany they've
all been so open and honest with me and
have helped me understand why these
things affected them so deeply no no no
no no no no no no no no no
oh listen you got this stay strong you
know how much you mean to me I love you
you love me too I may have ruined my
chances because of Alyssa but I would do
it all again
um later in the game my relationship
with Alyssa was the number one priority
and the game kind of seemed to be second
place at that point but she's amazing
like can you really blame me
I've learned that the people in the
house are amazing that I had some
generalized thoughts that were
definitely unfounded and moving forward
I have to be the one to take
responsibility and continue learning and
growing and continuing this journey
outside of the house
foreign